tf1 20 heures avec dominique baudis
ticket modérateur le combat du 13 mai
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
condamne la réforme de la sécurité
sociale mais pas d'unité d'action
nouveau coup d'état en ouganda des
militaires favorables à l'ancien
président aux beautés ont pris le
pouvoir à kampala cisjordanie tensions
persistantes c'est le constat de notre
envoyé spécial robert bouchard la
répression israélienne déclenché des
grèves
drew retrouve drouot après quatre ans
d'exil l'hôtel des ventes devient beau
et pratique
bonsoir de très nombreuses perturbations
marqueront la journée de demain
la cgt la cfdt et la fédération de
l'éducation nationale ont en effet lancé
des mots d'ordre de grève et 16
organisations sociales se sont
d'ailleurs associés à cette journée
nationale d'action la liste des
entreprises touchées par la grève serait
trop longue à établir signalant
toutefois et parce que cela vous
concerne des coupures d'électricité dans
toute la france avec pour la région
parisienne des répercussions sur le
trafic du métro à prévoir également des
perturbations dans le trafic ferroviaire
dans la distribution du courrier dans
les services municipaux dans les caisses
de sécurité sociale ou de nombreux
clichés seront fermés des manifestations
seront organisées à paris et dans les
grandes villes de province les
organisateurs ont placé cette journée
nationale sous le signe de la défense de
la sécurité sociale françois bour quatre
objectifs pour les syndicats conventions
sociales médecins assurance maladie la
cgt la cfdt la fun les enseignants
exigent dans son cadre l'égalité de
l'accès aux soins ticket modérateur
d'ordre public pour les mutuelles 5 à
12% la charge des assurés les syndicats
réclament son abrogation
loi berger sur l'institution de deux
secteurs d'assurance sociale et sur la
réforme des hôpitaux
les syndicats demandent au parlement de
repousser cette proposition de loi
protection sociale elle doit être
assurée au plus haut niveau pour tous
voilà les quatre objectifs principaux
par conséquent de cette journée
nationale d'action pour la cgt il existe
aujourd'hui une grave menace si on la
sécurité sociale sont très grave qui
peut avec conséquences dramatiques
tous les assurés sociaux l'alliage parce
que monsieur bart ont trompé sciemment
l'opinion publique quand ils affirment
ces dispositions visent à trouver les
ressources supplémentaires parce qu elle
sociale et quand il prétend que les
mutualistes y trouveront leur compte
alors qu'il n'y a pas si longtemps il
reconnaissait son gouvernement que les
mutualistes et et les assurés sociaux
les plus économiques pour la sécurité
sociale
nous sommes donc en présence d'une
atteinte grave et il est ce que le faire
replonger 50 ans en arrière le système
de protection sociale conquis de haute
lutte par des décennies de luttes
syndicales et dans ces conditions il est
normal que les travailleurs réagissent
avec la vigueur que leur en proposer la
cgt n'accepterons jamais une assurance
pour les riches et une assistance pour
les pauvres
il s'agit de défendre un grand progrès
social de la société française une
assumeront toute leur responsabilité
pour jacques baron le ticket modérateur
d'ordre public est une des mesures
destinées à freiner les dépenses de la
sécurité sociale
il faut savoir que cette mesure fait
partie d'un plan d'ensemble celui du 25
juillet et que les français depuis dix
mois ont fait preuve d'un esprit de
responsabilité qui n'est pas resté sans
résultat vous savez que nous avons un
ralentissement de la dépense qui ne
suffit pas bien sûr pour assurer
l'avenir mais qui déjà est un grand
progrès
nous n'allons pas nous arrêter en chemin
ce serait ridicule et j'ajoute qu'au
delà de cet effort qui est demandé
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs pas tous les
mutualistes puisque certains mutualiste
déjà fond ce ticket modérateur et bien
au delà de cet effort je suis convaincu
que nous
vont faire beaucoup de choses ensemble
avec la mutualité et personnellement
j'entends mener des actions concertées
de la mutualité dans des domaines comme
la prévention comme l'éducation
sanitaire qui sont les domaines de
l'avenir la cftc et fo s'associe
également à cette journée nationale
notamment contre le ticket modérateur
mais sans participer aux grands hommes
malgré leurs divergences les centrales
syndicales se regroupent
demain autour de la sécurité sociale à
l'étranger maintenant en situation
extrêmement confuse en ouganda le
président monsieur bin essa a été
neutralisé par l'armée le chef de l'état
est isolé dans son palais à 30 km de la
capitale
la réalité du pouvoir appartient un
collectif militaire dirigée par le chef
d'état major david aujac un homme
d'ailleurs que le président de la
république voulait écarter et qui a
réussi à prendre de vitesse le chef de
l'état sur la situation à kampala jambes
demigneux depuis la chute d'idi amin
dada il ya treize mois la population
ougandaise a pris l'habitude des
changements du pouvoir elle avait
accueilli avec indifférence surtout à
kampala
l'éviction décidé avant-hier du chef
d'état-major son retour aujourd'hui à la
tête d'un collectif de militaires n'a
guère surpris
le nouveau chef du pays le troisième
depuis le renversement d'idi amin dada
est originaire de la tribu des langues
le grand homme d l'anguille et milton
obote est le premier président de la
république ougandaise dont sur ces
images
godfrey bin aïssa le président renversé
présidait les cérémonies du 17e
anniversaire
à ses côtés se tenait son successeur
l'ancien chef d'état major david vite et
ocak nul tonneau beauté réside à dar es
salaam en tanzanie en exil depuis le
mois de janvier 1971 lorsque parti pour
participer à une conférence du
commonwealth à singapour
il avait été renversé par son chef
d'état-major idi amin dada qui n'était
alors que général il est vraisemblable
que l'un des bus du collectif de
commandants militaires qui s'est saisi
du pouvoir ce matin et dont la majorité
d'origine languit va être de préparer le
retour au pouvoir de milton obote et qui
avait annoncé son désir de rentrer à
temps pas là le 27 mai détesté lorsqu'il
a été renversé en 1971
milton obote et après une traversée du
désert de 9 ans est devenu aujourd'hui
incontestablement populaire
en ouganda la situation est chaque jour
un peu plus tendue dans les territoires
occupés de cisjordanie
aujourd'hui le mouvement de grève de la
population arabe était assez largement
suivie dans certains villages les
autorités militaires israéliennes ont
cependant obliger les commerçants à
ouvrir boutique
cette protestation de la population
cisjordanienne fait suite à l'expulsion
de plusieurs notables chassés par les
israéliens
et ces mesures d'expulsion avait été
elle-même prise au lendemain de
l'attentât palestinien à hébron
au début de ce mois de mai sur cet
engrenage de la violence et de la
répression dans les territoires occupés
un reportage de notre envoyé spécial
robert bouchard kiryat arba citadelle
israélienne aux portes d'hébron c'est
ici que tout a commencé
kiryat arba c'est la plus grande
implantation juive en cisjordanie
occupée
et c'est surtout un fief du goush
emounim l'organisation des fanatiques de
la foi hebron la ville sainte des arabes
est à trois kilomètres et dans cette
ville sainte
il y a cinquante mille palestiniens et
une mosquée et dans cette mosquée il y a
aussi le tombeau d'abraham le patriarche
des juifs alors les juifs veulent y
baptiser leurs enfants
ouvrir une école israélite et ils
voudraient s'installer dans la ville
d'où les frictions d'abord les
affrontements ensuite parce que sans le
droit de faire peux pas t n'a pas aidé
rentrée du vin parce que c'est notre
synagogue les arabi nom s'était fondu
parce que notre loi s'est défendu de
mettre du vin dans leurs mosquées
alors qu'est ce qu'on en pense on a
pensé on va rien dire au gouvernement
parce que le gouvernement défende de ça
alors on entre un médecin dans une dans
un dans une boutique de bébé comme ça
dans huit bureaux dans cette bouteille
on à 12h20 et on m'a dit et moi je suis
fils était alors visite avec a baissé un
peu s'est pas défendu et personnes
savent et leur apporter le monsieur qui
fait la bri la circoncision
oui oui et après
il a fait naître la de baptême ont ils
abritent mais la pauvre du courage pour
faire une chose pareille les gens ici
qu'ils ont peur de ces de ceux d'avoir
des votes des votants dhien avec les
arabes
alors ils préfèrent réduction des
frictions des frictions avec les arabes
résultat de tout ceci il y a huit jours
un groupe de palestiniens a tiré sur les
juifs qui sortaient de la mosquée une
fusillade qui faisait cinq morts et 17
blessés
depuis les israéliens ont décrété le
couvre-feu et devront une heure par jour
les habitants ont droit de sortir pour
se ravitailler elles ont fait la queue
devant les boutiques qui n'ont plus
grand chose à offrir
nous avons pu tourner cinq minutes dans
la ville avant d'en être chassés par les
militaires personne ne peut rentrer ou
sortir d'hébron seul à passer les
barrages ces religieuses juives qui
profitent du couvre-feu qui on ferme les
arabes dans leurs maisons pour aller
prier sur le tombeau d'abraham
alors
bien d'autres villes de cisjordanie
occupée subi ce même couvre-feu il y à
des villages où depuis sept jours les
habitants ne peut plus sortir de leur
maison
spectaculaire victoire électorale des
sociaux démocrates du chancelier helmut
schmidt en république fédérale certes il
ne s'agissait que d'une élection
régionale mais la consultation était
particulièrement significative
elle se déroule est en effet en rhénanie
du nord westphalie c'est le land le plus
peuplé le plus représentatif avec 48 et
demi pour cent des voix les sociaux
démocrates sont très bien placés six
mois avant les élections générales du
mois d'octobre prochain
une analyse de notre correspondant
permanent bernard bolquère gentilles et
schmidt a toutes les chances de
l'emporter aux élections législatives
d'octobre prochain
c'est ce que l'on pense ici à bonn
aujourd'hui après le succès considérable
du parti du chancelier aux élections
régionales en rhénanie westphalie le
tiers des électeurs de toute la
république fédérale s'est en effet
prononcé très clairement en faveur des
sociaux-démocrates qui gagne plus de 3%
des voix par rapport à 1975 et obtienne
la majorité absolue au parlement
régional
l'échec de l'opposition ont dirigé par
franz josef strauss est important les
chrétiens démocrates enregistrent en
effet une de leurs plus fortes pertes
avec -3 8%
autre résultat important la disparition
des libéraux qui n'ont pas franchi la
barre des 5%
cet échec des alliés de monsieur schmidt
va sûrement polariser davantage encore
la campagne pour les prochaines
législatives en un duel schmitt strauss
c'est à dire gauche droite est peut-être
modifier radicalement le paysage
politique allemand
si l'élément modérateur libéral
disparaît ici bonne tf retour aux
affaires françaises l'ajustement du
franc vers est entré en vigueur
aujourd'hui un ajustement de 1,35 pour
cent il concerne dans un premier temps
le lait et la viande bovine et cette
mesure porte à 5,02 % le taux des
hausses des prix agricoles à la
production depuis le début de l'année 80
cet ajustement sera d'ailleurs appliqué
au sucre le 1er juillet et aux céréales
le 1er août d'autre part cet après midi
le chef de l'état a eu un entretien avec
monsieur raymond barre consacré à ces
problèmes agricoles
monsieur raymond barre recevra dans les
prochaines semaines les principaux
dirigeants des organisations
professionnelles et ce soir
manuel de la taille sur ce plateau
reçoit monsieur méhaignerie le ministre
de l'agriculture
oui monsieur le ministre il ya beaucoup
d'affolement dans les campagnes sur les
moyens d'avoir les 10% de hausse des
prix promis alors résumons 5% sur ces 10
% sont déjà faits et garantit aux
agriculteurs restent les 5 % suivant le
président de la république vient de
confirmer qu'en cas d'échec des
négociations de bruxelles
le 1er juin il y aurait une garantie de
hausse de 10% au total sur les prix
agricoles après consultation des
organisations professionnelles mais
quelles mesures nationales des mesures
simples concrètes que nous examinerons
dans les prochains jours au niveau du
premier ministre avec les organisations
professionnelles des mesures de nature
fiscale des mesures pour les jeunes qui
ont investi dernièrement et qui sont
dans une situation difficile et enfin
des mesures que je viens de prendre sur
les légumes sur le port ou sur les
céréales pour améliorer le revenu de ces
producteurs mesures fiscales ça veut
dire augmentation des remboursements de
tva soient des subventions du budget
pour équivaloir à une hausse de 10% des
prix agricoles
ce sont des mesures de ce type qui
peuvent être appliqués vite rapidement
concrètes et pour tous les agriculteurs
en substance moyen de pression sur nos
partenaires et en même temps une
certitude pour les agriculteurs y auront
le 1er juin de toute manière une hausse
de 10%
le gouvernement estime que devant une
forte augmentation des coûts des coûts
de production les agriculteurs ont des
droits
il l'a dit à bruxelles il l'a dit à
luxembourg et grâce à son opiniâtreté
nous avons obtenu une première série de
décisions et d'un accord et 8,7 à corps
et 8 nous disons que coûte que coûte
nous l'appliquerons avant le 31 mai
merci monsieur ministre c'est par la
visite d'une léproserie que le pape jean
paul ii a achevé ce matin son périple
africain voyage vous le savez de dix
jours qui l'a conduit dans six pays
différents
le souverain pontife regagne rome ce
soir vous voyez les toutes dernières
images de son voyage africain et cette
visite de la léproserie
le pape regagne donc ce soir le vatican
mais il reprendra très bientôt son bâton
de pèlerin pour se rendre en france
il séjournera dans notre pays du 30 mai
au 2 juin ce sera la première visite
pontificale depuis cent soixante six ans
et des centaines de milliers de fidèles
sont attendus à l'occasion des
différentes cérémonies qui marqueront ce
voyage ceux qui veulent y assister
doivent d'ailleurs s'y prendre dès
maintenant pour organiser leurs
déplacements pour prévoir leur
hébergement et jacques hébert nous
fourni quelques informations de
caractère pratique irait venir à paris
pour cette visite de jean paul ii vous
vous heurterez essentiellement à deux
difficultés les transports et
l'hébergement les transports d'abord
sachez qu'entre le 30 mai le 2 juin
il ne reste presque plus un seul quart
de disponibles à travers toute la france
sachez également que la sncf prévoit un
certain nombre de trains spéciaux déjà
dix sont retenues dès aujourd'hui pour
transporter plus de dix mille personnes
et puis air inter programme à des vols
spéciaux pour tous ces problèmes de
transport et bien il faut vous adresser
à la direction des pèlerinages de
l'évêché de votre diocèse
deuxième difficulté l'hébergement à
paris à un moment déjà critique
d'ailleurs avec cette époque les débuts
de la flûte traditionnelle et touristes
d'après les premiers enseignements que
nous avons pu obtenir
il ne reste que très peu de place dans
les cent dix mille chambres d'hôtel de
paris de sa région très proches très peu
de place également dans les centres de
séjour et sur les terrains de camping le
taux de remplissage est d'ores et déjà
en moyenne de 80%
le mieux est donc de vous renseigner à
l'office de tourisme de paris dont
l'adresse est le téléphone s'inscrivent
à l'instant sur votre écran c'est
également cet office qui vous indiquera
certaines places payantes disponibles
chez l'habitant
quant aux cérémonies et bien pas la
peine de courir après quelques billets
ou quelques places privilégiées
seuls les handicapés auront droit à des
places réservées à l'avant s'il faudra
pour cela qu'ils s'adressent à leur
association
et puis si malgré tout cela vous ne
pouvez venir à paris et bien sachez que
tf1 retransmettra la quasi totalité de
cette visite de jean paul ii en france
avec plus de dix heures de direct
vendredi 30 mai de 16h à 18h arrivée du
pape à orly réception par le président
de la république place de la concorde
puis cortège à travers paris jusqu'à
notre dame samedi 31 mai de direct dès
9h50 à 11 heures visite du souverain
pontife
fa l'elysée et de 18 heures à 19 heures
45 messe à la basilique de saint denis
dimanche 1er juin de 10 heures 15 à 13
heures la messe au bourget qui sera le
point culminant de cette visite et puis
lundi de juin de 15h30 à 17h messe à la
basilique de lisieux
enfin bien entendu entre le 30 mai le 2
juin nous vous proposons de larges
résumé de cette visite papale dans
toutes nos éditions quotidiennes
d'informations nous vous aussi
d'aujourd'hui dans les universités de
grenoble et de nice à grenoble et forces
de l'ordre ont fait évacuer 300
étudiants qui avaient dressé des
barricades près du campus il y a eu des
bagarres avec échanges de pierres et de
grenades lacrymogènes les associations
juives de france démentent que le rappel
en israël drame prix mort et était de me
et été demandée par kid rock phil
abraham primor le représenter en france
du mouvement sioniste mondial déclare
pour sa part qu'il est contre la
formation d'un lobby juif en france
fusillade ce matin en plein paris dans
le quartier des halles entre des
policiers de l'antigang et de gangsters
l'un des truands été tué et l'autre a
réussi à prendre la fuite les gangsters
avaient hier matin attaqué un
supermarché près de mantes un jeune
homme avait été tué au cours de ce hold
et puis un nouveau drame de
l'autodéfense dans la région parisienne
un directeur un ancien directeur de la
banque de france a battu son jambes qui
l'avaient pris pour un cambrioleur
après deux tentatives de cambriolage de
sa villa monsieur fourneaux l'avait
acheté un fusil de chasse rentrante dans
la nuit d'un voyage d'affaires sont
jambes s'était rendu sans prévenir chez
ses beaux-parents et rendez vous demain
dans journal de 13 heures en direct de
vienne il mourousi recevra le chancelier
bruno kreisky et ceci à l'avant veille
du 25e anniversaire du traité sur
l'autriche à cette occasion les 15 et 16
mai des rencontres politiques
importantes sont prévues entre les
différents ministres affaires étrangères
présents et notamment entre l'américain
et demande du ski et le soviétique
gromyko entre jean françois poncet et et
le monde puisque dix rencontres que jean
françois poncet a confirmé dans journal
de 13h pour la première fois le mini
affaires étrangères nous a fait
découvrir la cellule de crise sorte de
pc opérationnel cette cellule entrera en
fonction au quai d'orsay dès qu'il y
aura un point chaud quelque part dans le
monde une crise où les intérêts et la
vie des citoyens français seront
impliqués
sur ces capitales pour que cette cellule
puisse record d'arrivée des réfugiés
cubains aux usa rien que pour la journée
d hier ils étaient plus de 4000 un parti
à bord de 60 de bateaux actuellement les
réfugiés cubains aux états unis sont au
nombre de 36 nouveaux drames en italie
un fonctionnaire de l'antiterrorisme été
tué ce matin à venise alors qu'il
sortait de son domicile cet assassinat
porte à 19 le monde des victimes du
terrorisme depuis le début de l'année
les anglais buts de plus en plus ce
marché comme à les deux tiers souhaite
que la grande bretagne se retire du
marché comme à cela selon un sondage
publié dans le daily mail c'est un
retournement complet des tendances par
rapport au référendum de 75 était alors
67% pour son maintien
et puis du sport un nouveau record du
monde cette fois en soit la perche
record réussi hier par le polonais qu à
kiewit ch avec ça m'aide 72 5072 soit 5
centimètres de mieux que le précédent
record d'europe réussi par thierry
vigneron le 1er mai
et puis excellente performance son
lancement du poids de l'allemande de
l'est ilona souple anaqua pose d'un
milliard elle améliorée de 9 cm le
record du monde du lancement du corps le
nouveau record est désormais porté à 22
mètres 45 demain des nuages et de la
pluie sur les régions s'étendant du
finistère aux pyrénées et à la
méditerranée
ce temps médiocre sera parfois
accompagnée d'orages sur les contreforts
sud des massifs montagneux et puis
surtout le reste de la france est bien
le temps sera ensoleillé et chaud comme
il était aujourd'hui signalant cependant
quelques passages nuageux de la
normandie au nord des alpes
et puis compte tenu de ces prévisions
optimistes
lagence pour les économies d'énergie
recommande l'arrêt des appareils de
chauffage
les commissaires priseurs et les
amateurs de vente aux enchères vont
retrouver leurs habitudes avec
l'inauguration demain de la nouvelle
salle des ventes drouot 80 pendant les
quatre ans de travaux la salle avait été
transféré sur la rive gauche à la garde
horse et un transfert provisoire qui
avait d'ailleurs permis d'attirer une
nouvelle clientèle
la première vente dans les nouveaux
locaux aura lieu dans huit jours mais
d'ici là une opération portes ouvertes
permettra au public de visiter les
nouvelles installations que nous fait
découvrir
christiane de la cua de nouveau les
marteaux d'ivoire vont pas au rythme des
enchères sur la rive droite de la seine
reconstruit moderniser climatisé doux
aux 80 doit aujourd'hui répondre aux
impératifs de son temps tout en restant
bien intégré dans son quartier
le vieux drouot poussiéreux des années
1850 a dit qu ils retrouvent une
nouvelle vie
première réaction était il nécessaire de
le rétablir sur son ancien emplacement
un secteur où la circulation est très
difficile
réponse un parking payant de 400 places
a été aménagé
sera-t-il suffisant pour résoudre les
problèmes de stationnement ceci est au
rez-de-chaussée le petit groupe composé
de deux salles des ventes pourra
fonctionner en totale indépendance et
notamment c'est nouveau en nocturne et
le dimanche
selon la tradition les salles reste
tendue de rouge la couleur par
excellence qui met en valeur les pièces
présentées des plafonds sont équipés de
grues mobiles d'éclairage qui montent et
descendent pour mieux cerner les objets
drew 80 qu'on française salle des ventes
répartis sur trois niveaux
elles sont situées autour d'un foyer
central d'où le public peut circuler
d'une vente à nu les salles figurer en
rose sur le dessin sont des magasins de
stockage éclairé par des doom de
plexiglas qui laissent passer la lumière
du jour lumière zénithale une salle de
prestige des espaces drouot où se feront
les ventes de très haute qualité
une salle qui peut s'agrandir par un jeu
de poison mobile et qui atteindra 300 m²
dès le 14 mai grâce à une opération
portes ouvertes le public sera admis à
découvrir ses nouvelles salles et avoir
deux expositions l'une qui retrace les
ventes aux enchères et le passé de trop
ou ses heures de gloire ces grandes
ventes et une autre qui présente des
pièces mises en vente lors de
l'ouverture le 20 mai prochain
tapisseries tableaux meubles objets
statues elle un public qui regrettera la
disparition de la petite brocante
reste encore à savoir si face aux
marchands toujours très nombreux le
particulier pourra emporter les enchères
et si nous pourrons retrouver notre
première place sur le marché nolin nous
sommes tout à fait compétitif déjà dans
certaines spécialités que la saison
dernière a vu se dérouler une vente
extraordinaire des stones japonaise et
que la vente arras mines scène a fait de
paris
un élément leader sur le marché de l'art
primitif
non puisque aujourd'hui il ya une crise
qui s'ouvre chez les commissaires
priseurs
on peut se demander si les entreprises
privées finalement ne vont pas être
aussi de nouvelles salles de ventes
je crois que nous sommes absolument pas
là et que le projet de réforme qui nous
a été soumis comporte un élément
essentiel qui le maintient notre statut
d'officier ministériel auquel nous
sommes très attachés
le marché dollar considéré comme valeur
sûre reste florissant avec un nouveau
souffle
drouot qui a réalisé en 79 un chiffre
d'affaires de 800 millions de francs
trouvera-t-elle une nouvelle expansion
sur le marché international de l'art à
cannes c'était aujourd'hui la troisième
journée du festival
après la projection de fantastique à et
des héritières les festivaliers ont pu
voir le dernier film d'ettore scola la
terrasse jacky dié nous en parler il
nous décrit aussi l'atmosphère dans
laquelle se déroule ce festival auquel
il assiste pour tf1
comment vous dire j'ai déjà vu de très
beaux films à ce festival de cannes mais
si je ne les avais pas vus que me
manquerez ti peut-être sourire par ci
une larme par la presque rien c'est déjà
un petit peu fané dans une armoire de la
mémoire
et puis à cannes ce sentiment de déjà-vu
et renforcée par l'ambiance le cinéma de
la croisette
l'exhibitionnisme gratuit est restée
charmant de la plage et pourtant je vous
assure que je n'aime pas beaucoup cette
phrase sever désabusé la chair est
triste hélas et j'ai lu tous les livres
c'est pourtant un petit peu ce que
répète le film que nous avons vu la
terrasse les stories comme étant escola
est un grand créateur sur sa scène de la
terrasse il observe et nous donne à voir
des zones de 50 ans les intellectuels
qui s'effondre qui se laisse rongé par
leur passé ils n'imaginent plus qu'ils
ne rêvent plus leur avenir c'est une
histoire triste qui fait rire et
d'ailleurs comment serait-il autrement
avec vittorio gassman en députés
communistes eelv montagne asie
producteur de films marcello mastroianni
journaliste jean louis trintignant
scénariste serge reggiani fonctionnaires
de la télé quelle distribution et quel
dialogues drôles fin plein de ses
phrases que l'on aurait aimé dire quand
on a l'esprit d'escalier film pourtant
bien long et qui amuse et qui fera
réfléchir avec complaisance tous ceux
qui sur toutes les terrasses du monde
dit certes interminablement sur la fin
de notre civilisation
ettore scola du sud de le france et vu
que je vous dise qu'il s'agit d'un clip
très amusant pour lui de jusqu'à la fin
un jour le lie ces deux arts ou henry
jusqu'à rappeler
voilà le festival a donc commencé
doucement mais déjà mercredi ce sera le
retour de cure aux samoa vendredi the
big red one du grand samuel fuller
samedi all that jazz de robert fau safin
dont on parle déjà beaucoup ici à cannes
lundi
fellini mardi à l'aréna mon oncle
d'amérique
non le festival de cannes ne s'endort
pas sur son passé il a un bel avenir et
pour l'avenir immédiat à 23h40 joseph
poli pour le dernier journal toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité vous souhaite
de passer une très bonne soirée
merci de votre attention